1968 le droit l'orgasme 1 voilà
quand il y avait eu des travaux à
l'assemblée nationale je reviens dans
mon bureau et il y avait un petit frigo
qui
ressortait de la boiserie je regarde et
les ouvriers qui devaient se livrer à
quelques activités qui n'était pas de la
rénovation j'avais trouvé un énorme
gollnisch et d'ardeur et ans et derrière
le frigo et des revues pornographiques
donc j'ai regardé les revues mais il
fallait me débarrasser de l'outil mais
si je peux pas le jeter dans la voiture
est bien cachée à temps mais les
huissiers je me dis s'il le trouve dans
la cub elle ils vont se dire la mère
bachelot quand même elle n'a peut être
pas alors me voilà partie avec l'outil
dans mon sac pour le mettre dans une
poubelle et chaque fois que sur le
boulevard saint germain j'avançais au
poids de la poubelle je trouver
quelqu'un que je connaissais le genoa et
julien j'ai trouvé jean louis debré il
est pas jeter le truc c'est drôle vous
êtes génial
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux